how's that pie for breakfast wyatt
we're vegan we're gonna be vegan soon so
eat that pie while you can
[Music]
hey i'm hannah and i'm the world's
okayist mom and i'm here today to talk
to you about the seven day vegan
challenge now you guys have seen this
all over the internet because you've
been asking me non-stop to try it
and this is a series where you ask and
we deliver so we're gonna give it a shot
it's gonna be seven days
family of four one painfully picky eater
and i'll let you guess who that
is wish us luck guys so what is the
seven day vegan challenge well it's
exactly how it sounds it's seven days of
eating vegan
no animal products simple enough our
family's eating habits
don't really rely much on animal
products to begin with each person has
very different tastes in food
i'm kind of like a plant lover i'm a
salad hoe so la so matt likes to eat a
lot of food he likes to feel full
but it's not like he overeats he has a
fast metabolism
and so he just likes to be full jackson
is my dream eater
he just came out of me hungry and has
never stopped eating scents he's like a
garbage disposal
then there's wyatt
he's pretty much on the white diet where
white foods are good
if there's a speck of green in his food
he will find it and he will remove
it you excited to be vegan yeah
i don't know if you really are but okay
this is my vegan grocery haul i know
that fruit is always
safe to get and then fresh veggies so i
got a lot of that
i don't think this is enough food for
the week but it ended up costing about
50
more than my average grocery trip and
then while i was at the grocery store i
had to say
goodbye to one of the most important
things in my life
goodbye cheese i will miss you
so day one i was feeling pretty prepared
for breakfast and lunch
i had prepped overnight oats the night
before
for the boys and then for matt and i i
made freezer smoothie packs with all
this good stuff in them
let's see how this tastes
this is really good
really healthy everything was going
smoothly until it was time for me
to make my coffee i have a very
specific shade of coffee that i need and
it's a very specific ratio of coffee
the strength of the coffee and the half
and half that's going in it
so i bought soy creamer and coconut
creamer throughout the week i
tried various mixtures of both i just
don't like it i have a very open-minded
palette and
this is the one thing like the one food
i can't budge on so for matt's lunch i
got him what's called a rainbow wrap
it's exactly how you'd imagine like a
tree
wrapped up in a tortilla if i started
him off with like the most intensely
vegan lunch
then the rest would be a nice surprise
now i'm feeling it
healthy manipulation i do it all the
time
this week shouldn't be that bad i think
it's gonna be good so for lunches i did
eventually find
some vegan bread i decided to make a sun
butter and jelly sandwich
despite the fact that that vegan bread
straight up tasted like
fresh hay night one the dinner was just
you know my dream meal a big ol salad i
was
so excited for this dinner but i was
very worried about how the kids would
react to it i
only love black beans and rice
that's not true you like white beans i
don't want
the beans on it wyatt ate his salad
and i was shook
i mean to the core like when he took the
bite of broccoli i pinched myself it's
almost like he ate more vegetables in
this one meal than he's eaten in the
last six months
whose plate is that nice your plate
so day two woke up feeling great feeling
healthy made a really nice breakfast i
bought this vegan cream cheese because i
figured the toast needed a little oomph
um
uh this one i'm serious
this vegan cream cheese rocked my world
how is it
a mustache it was so good
hey jackson are you enjoying your
breakfast
you're wearing it a little bit good
breakfast everyone's happy
and then i made my coffee and that was
the start of the worst day of the week
no
that day in particular was a very big
day for me at work i had a
huge video to shoot i was making all of
this
glorious food and i did not realize that
i could not eat a single bite of any of
it
this is the thing i work for tasty
this is what i look forward to in my job
i get to
snack on just the best food you can
imagine i was
so devastated that i couldn't eat it it
was a frustrating
day so here we are enjoying our tikka
masala
i actually do like it and i would eat it
again
i am the first one home tonight so i'm
going to make dinner
and i'm absolutely starving for my shoot
so
i'm gonna make a vegan pizza and i think
the boys will actually like it i think
they'll be excited for a pizza tonight
the first few bites i was like oh my god
this is delicious
yes bread carbs but then as i started
going in on my slice the cheese is a
little gluey
it's sticking to my teeth i honestly
would have preferred it as more of a
flatbread without the cheese
but you know we're all very hungry so we
all ate it
much glue you like it and then
it came time for wyatt to try it what's
the plus
the crust is right there you want me to
cut it for you
what do you think
you like the pizza mommy made it
from scratch why
do you like the pizza he didn't eat it
he opted to eat salad
instead of his pizza which you know
means
that pizza was not good so we started
the morning off
trying some coconut yogurt that's made
from coconut milk
with some vegan cereal and raspberries
you like it
why do you like it so far i'm bad in a
thousand on breakfast like
win win win win win it is going great
day three of this copy
better i guess lunches i feel like i'm
packing a lot of chips
this week but other than that pretty
easy
this lunch look good yeah
did you like your lunch yesterday yep
that was amazing
really now i thought that pizza would be
the safe bet for dinner but it just
didn't turn out
the way i planned it all so for
tonight's dinner
i decided to make pasta i know i make a
really good pasta sauce
so i was feeling really excited about
this lentil pasta that i found that has
protein in it
so i made that roasted some broccoli and
that was our dinner
yeah it's good okay that's all that
matters wyatt gets into these weird
moods sometimes at dinner time where
he won't feed himself because he's just
a diva
he'll sit there and be like you can
offer me a bite if you'd like
and i might eat it but he went straight
for the broccoli on his plate which was
very confusing but very awesome he
eventually
did eat the pasta but not without
letting us all know that we're very
lucky to have him
eating the pasta at our table do you
like it
good thank you wyatt your presence is
appreciated
you know we're not worthy very rushed
breakfast this morning
because i have to get ready and be on
set today
what do you think wyatt thumbs down but
he's eating it all
what i was shooting at work was a food
competition show
and it was me versus my co-worker
matthew
we had to make this crazy dish and so
some things happened
i completely forgot about this vegan
challenge and
my food was ice cream and cake and it
had eggs
dairy all that stuff so i ended up
having to
taste it russell tried my meatball
don't tell them
they're okay oh i just ruined everything
today i gotta go like double vegan
tonight to make up for it i'm gonna eat
some grass here's the thing
like i can't put food in front of
someone for a cooking competition
without tasting it
my family doesn't even know that this
happened so i'm
sorry i failed you i didn't mean to and
i was
a little bit deceitful tonight's dinner
is gonna be like a burrito bowl
you know with these new foods that we're
trying i don't know how spicy something
is going to be
it might be a little spicy it ended up
being very spicy and a little too spicy
for the kids and they were
not happy spicy little spicy
i hate wasting food so i ended up eating
three or four times
more chorizo than i normally would and i
forced matt to do the same
the flavor is good what is it
i think you're gonna get the poops
day five matt and i decided to do a date
night we decided to put our vegan selves
out into the world which was something i
was really dreading because
i didn't want to be that person who's
ordering at a restaurant
and asking a million questions about the
ingredients so we went to this little
wine bar by our house what we ended up
being able to order at the wine bar
was a plate of olives a little veggie
salad
from there we were still so hungry so we
decided to stop at this little british
pub
someone was looking down on us we opened
the menu and they have
a vegan burger this burger was
so delicious it had vegan mayo lettuce
tomato on a vegan bun
that didn't taste like the wheat had
just been pulled from the earth
it was so good and then we curly fries
with it
it was so good so on day six i decided
to take it to the next level and
i went to taco bell and could i also get
no sour cream or nacho cheese on those
it was a lengthy order it was kind of
annoying but i
i was so excited to try it the thing
that i love the most
about crunchwraps is the nacho cheese
sauce
so i miss it i should have added some
guacamole to this i feel like guacamole
would be really good
for dinner asian food is something that
we've been lacking this week because
i could not quite grasp how to cook it
vegan i was struggling with that so we
decided to
look for a vegan asian restaurant like i
went crazy on this menu and i over
ordered i was like ready to shovel all
of it into my face
are you just going for it so end of day
six i'm feeling great
i have it cooked in a whole day i was
really optimistic
and then it all fell apart
chocolate croissant but they're not
vegan babe
so we have to make something else
it's okay croissants are extremely
difficult to make vegan croissants i
don't even know
i gave your toast with peanut butter and
jelly right here
okay why do you want them
[Music]
you like it yeah
were you hungry after the meltdown at
breakfast
i decided that for dinner i would make
something that i knew they would like
we were going to my parents house for
dinner so i knew i had to bring food
for us to make and i decided on vegan
mac and cheese
not as easy as it looks while i was
making my vegan dinner my mom was making
delicious
teriyaki salmon oh i want that so bad
i never thought i would be like wow that
salmon is so
tempting but on that day on the final
day of our vegan challenge
that salmon was looking really good so
we made it through all seven days i
didn't think we'd make it through that
easily
and i didn't think the kids would be so
receptive to the challenge
so the next day after it was over i
decided to surprise them with a little
something special
[Music]
croissants they're going to be so happy
surprise it's very hot be careful
good breakfast jackson
my kids got their chocolate croissants
okay guys they got the chocolate
croissants
so what did i learn on this seven day
vegan challenge well i learned
first that it's actually not that
difficult to be vegan if you're cooking
a lot of your own meals
it's not that much more expensive it's
not that difficult to get your protein
either next i learned how to get wyatt
to eat vegetables
i don't think you guys realize how huge
this is for me and how much of a
struggle it's been for all of us
i mean ever since he could eat solids
this is like the peak of motherhood for
me right now
and last i learned that i really want to
continue
doing as much of a vegan challenge as we
possibly can
going forward but that said i know
that i will never be a full vegan
because i cannot
deal with vegan creamer in my coffee i'm
sorry i have to have my half and half
i can't do it so that's all i got for
today i'm hannah and if you've tried the
seven day vegan challenge
let me know in the comments tell me how
it went or if you have any ideas for
future food challenges for us to try
leave that in the comments too or you
can always text me this is a real number
and i don't always answer every single
text because i get a lot but i do
read every single one now if you'll
please excuse me i have some decent copy
to make because it's been
so long since i've had it until next
[Music]
time
[Music]
anything with curry or masala i'm just
like
in cloud on cloud9 so this is really
good
i'm stoked